ein anderes wichtiges thema ist dass das
wir natürlich in einem bundesländern zum
beispiel in mecklenburg vorpommern
möglicherweise gar nicht anreisen können
obwohl wir fest gebucht haben
da dürfen die hotels nur zu 60 prozent
die betten belegen
in niedersachsen sind es sogar nur 50
prozent also tatsächlich da deutschland
im sommer jahr 100 prozent ausgebucht
ist heißt das dass einige menschen die
eine feste sommerbuchungen haben dann
möglicherweise in die röhre schauen
und ich habe mich mit tobias woitendorf
dem chef des tourismusverbandes
unterhalten oder war in dieser sendung
muss dann letztlich dann in den sauren
apfel beißen und zu hause bleiben weil
wir haben es jetzt gelernt der hotelier
darf gar nicht alle gäste beherbergen
also für sommer kann man noch nicht
sagen weil wir eben hoffen dass wir noch
ein bisschen zulegen können wenn wir
jetzt über pfingsten blicken heute sagen
61 prozent der tiere können gebucht sein
das praktische beispiele zählt wohl
schon 80 prozent der zimmer gebucht sind
dann steht der hotelier in der tat jetzt
vor der schwierigen situation nicht alle
studieren zu müssen aber eben diese 60
prozent wieder zu erreichen das heißt 20
prozent wieder zu stornieren
es gibt dafür kein richtig kann man den
rechtsanwalt noch mal fragen kein
richtig gutes mittel finde ich das
einzige was ich mir vorstellen kann ist
man das mal ist dass man dass man hinten
bei den buchungen anfängt also
diejenigen die zuletzt gebucht hat eben
wieder aus buchen muss eine blöde
situation stellt man sich anders vor dem
ersten tragen will
aber lässt sich unter diesem geschehen
unter dem platz arbeiten auch möglich
wende also tatsächlich wirklich ein
heißes thema wir wollen mal hoffen wir
dass die hoteliers sehen wir sind
verbunden mit damir hanken er hat auf
wangerooge der schönen nordseeinsel
wangerooge zwei hotels hallo herr hankel
wir hatten uns ja auch schon mal
unterhalten
sie haben das ein bisschen panik weil
sie nicht genau wissen wen sie absagen
wie stellt sich die lage jetzt bei ihnen
da muss natürlich strukturiert vorgehen
[Musik]
wie vorhin erwähnt werden ausschau
halten der früher gebucht hat stammgäste
längere aufenthalte muss man auch
berücksichtigen dass viele faktoren die
hinein in diese entscheidungsspiel wird
nicht schön ist er denn die man den
image kratzen und wir hoffen nun dass
wir keine rechtliche einbüßen haben dass
wir uns in so eine situation auch mit
diesen sachen umschlagen müssen da wo es
auch die hoteliers und das nur um viele
veränderung auf uns zukommen hier wird
sicherheit eine sehr schwierige lage
aber stellen wir uns mal vor ich hätte
bei ihnen gebucht hat was raten sie soll
ich anrufen und fragen kann ich den
urlaub planen oder warte ich dass sie
mir absagen was würden sie mir als gast
empfehlen was ich ihnen empfehlen würde
das gas das ist einfach dass wir einen
buchen aufnehmen
die optional stattfindet da mussten uns
natürlich einig sein da mussten sie auch
darauf eingehen als gast genau das ist
das für die insel ist es noch nicht ganz
klar wie viel prozent wer überhaupt
belegen dürfen
um was es überhaupt losgeht für uns auf
der insel das ist auch noch nicht ganz
klar
wir raten ab aber die buchen an sich
selbst würde ich ihn empfehlen
vorzunehmen und ressourcen auf der insel
sind noch vorhanden man kann unter dem
betrieb untereinander austauschen und
die gäste zu beherbergen weil der wunsch
auch die insel zu kommen ist laut und
telefon
ich wünsche ich darf alles gute
natürlich aber eine frage wir haben auch
den test gemacht wir haben also an den
hotspots an den küsten tatsächlich
hoteliers angerufen da war bisher noch
nicht die rede davon dass möglicherweise
buchung wieder durchs rost fallen ist
das so vielleicht auch eine strategie um
zu sagen ich sage jetzt erst mal
buchungen guckt dann was ich belegen
darf und sage dann ab ich bleibe hier
auf jeden fall egal was für eine
strategie eingesetzt wird das kannst du
den gast jährlich ist in jedem moment
das ja weiß worauf er sich einstellen
muss
wir bauen muss das ist mein meine bitte
an alle hoteliers die überhaupt so ein
vorhaben machen und einfach über buchen
oder buchen und wenn wir den gästen
nicht auf der ehrlichkeit ebene arbeiten
ehrlich sein
von den gästen kommunizieren die
verstehen die lage die sind auch sehr
gut informiert und hoffe dass jetzt
besonders über die pfingsten feiertage
gekommen und alle gesund daraus
marschieren
das wünsche ich auch ich frag doch mal
unseren rechtsanwalt an kempkens wenn
ich jetzt gebucht habe und erfahre jetzt
aus meinem pfingsturlaub oder aus meinem
sommerurlaub wird jetzt wegen
behördlicher anordnungen nichts habe ich
es recht habe ich da also dieser punkt
vertragliche ehrlichkeit ist richtig und
wenn der heute hier jetzt überbucht ist
ohne dass er das in irgendeiner form
vorhersehen konnte weil einfach die
situation nicht absehbar wie wir es hier
gerade gehört haben es ist doch alles so
ein bisschen offen
dann haben wir einen fall von
unmöglichkeit das heißt der hotelier
darf dann eben von diesem vertrag
zurücktreten wenn ich eine anzahlung
geleistet habe obwohl im moment ganz
ehrlich sagen muss für den reisen dann
bitte möglichst keine anzahlungen wenn
das irgendwie geht dann bekommt man aber
die anzahlungen wenn das dann storniert
wird zurück und hat dann keinen
schadenersatzanspruch für eine höhere
oder teurere ersatz buchung weil der
hotelier ja auch nichts dazu kann und
noch mal auch die frage jetzt zum thema
hotelgewerbe wenn da ein pool
angekündigt ist den ich vielleicht nicht
nutzen kann
wie verhält es sich mit solchen mängeln
also das sind vertragliche mängel wenn
ich in dem katalog oder auf der homepage
beispielsweise zu sagen habe die jetzt
bewohner bedient nicht erfüllt werden
können dann habe ich einen anspruch auf
erstattung so dass also die hoteliers
wie wir das gerade gehört haben so im
wege der vertraglichen ehrlichkeit
einfach auch aufgefordert sind hier auf
diese mängel im vorhinein hinzuweisen
dass man also schon sagt das und dieses
angebot könnt ihr wahrscheinlich nicht
wahrnehmen dann ist das vertraglich auch
in ordnung
dieser hinweis unterbleibt gibt es
schwierigkeiten so dass wenn also ein
bestimmtes angebot unterbreitet ist oder
ein zusatzangebot das wird nicht
geliefert
auch teil erstattungsansprüche der
reisenden